[Music]
here in this video we will showcase 20
of the biggest octopus squid kraken and
cephalopod monsters from movies so
without any further ado please subscribe
and if you already have then let's get
on with this monster content
20. rather from the star wars universe
these were large hyper carnivorous
cephalopods that were native to the
planet tuan kitty regarded as one of the
most dangerous beasts in the galaxy they
are not necessarily aquatic but are seen
in many types of habitats including
terrestrial ones and also seen in space
sometimes in spaceships that is wrethers
are around 20 feet or 6 meters long
including the tentacles
19 the giant squid
from the 2018 movie the meg a
submersible that was sent to rescue a
crew of another in the depths of the
marianas trench was attacked by a giant
squid that was around 9 meters or 30
feet long
as the squid was about to crush the
glass cockpit of the submersible it was
attacked by a giant megalodon shark and
was killed
18. ammonite ammonites were a group of
cephalopods that inhabited the earth
millions of years ago ammonites are
similar to nautilus in appearance but
were more closely related to squids and
octopus
in the film mysterious island a giant
ammonite measuring 10 to 14 meters or 34
to 45 feet long rises from the trench
and attacks captain nemo and the
castaways in the 1954 mysterious island
film
17. watcher in the water
seen in the fellowship of the ring the
watcher was a horrifying and mysterious
beast with many tentacles living in a
stagnant pool or a lake near the west
gate of moria it is one of the old ones
creatures that are described as older
and more foul than even orcs that dwell
in the deep places of the world this
creature was around 15 meters or 50 feet
long
16. gargantus seen in the latest mcu
movie doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness gergantus had eight tentacles
and many other tendrils beneath its head
that also houses a single large eye this
creature was seen in new york and was
around 50 feet long including the
tentacles it was the second creature
doctor strange had to battle in the
movie the other ones we won't tell
fifteen aliens they fell apart these
octopus monsters or the aliens and
valipots were one of the first of the
aliens to start appearing on planet
earth in the movie monsters of 2010 they
have four insectoid legs and many
tentacles that they use to interact with
the world around them this kind is the
least alien looking one mostly because
they resemble an octopus
they are nocturnal creatures around 50
feet long and weighing 40 tons
14. octolus octolus is the main
antagonist in the 1998 horror film deep
rising it is a huge sea creature of
unknown origin the octolist's body
consists of many long slimy tentacles
with mouths on each of them on all of
these tentacles and a body with a big
mouth and two big eyes its normal
habitat is the ocean flow and could be
hundreds of years old its size is
estimated to be around 15 to 24 meters
anywhere between 50 to 80 feet long
13. giant squid this giant squid is an
antagonist from the movie twenty
thousand leagues under the sea it
attacks a submersible called a nautilus
near the end of the movie the creature
doesn't look any different from a
typical giant squid that is seen in real
life but the size is double this giant
squid is around 21 to 24 meters long or
70 to 80 feet and is very aggressive
given the fact that it attacked a
submarine
12 tentacles from planet x seen in the
movie the mist the tentacles from planet
x are large flesh tone tentacles with
rows of spikes on either of their sides
and down the middle of the tentacle is a
row of two suckers like those of a squid
and the bites of these suckers appear to
be corrosive and poisonous they seem to
be a part of a larger creature estimated
to be anywhere around 50 to 150 feet or
15 to 45 meters long
11. the giant octopus this is a giant
cevalopod kaiju who first appeared in
king kong vs godzilla it then returned
in alternate endings of the movies
frankenstein vs baragon and finally in
the war of the gargantuas it is
essentially just an overgrown 100 feet
or 30 meters tall octopus with no
special abilities other than the guts to
attack kong and the other touhou kaijus
number 10 the maya squid seen in kong
skull island of 2017 the gigantic
leviathas also known as the my squid or
the river devil or the river monster is
at 27 to 33 meters or 90 to 110 feet
long species of giant salt waters of
valaport that is found on skull island
it is a red-colored ambush predator that
lurks in the waterways of that island
and has a lot of tentacles which is a
dinner delight for kong
number 9 gezora this is a mutated
cuttlefish kaiju created by toho that
first appeared in the 1970 touhou film
space amoeba gezora could emit a cooling
gas most likely to protect it from the
warm and dry atmosphere
it uses its tentacles to great effect
being able to strike objects from far a
distance
he is 30 meters or 100 feet tall and is
mind controlled by aliens known as devop
number eight virus
seen in the movie gamera vs virus this
kaju is a large space tentacled villain
of the turtle camaro its main attack is
his constricting tentacles on both sides
of his body and head he possesses a
sharp beak and can make the tentacles on
his head forming to spear-like points
he can survive in space underwater and
on land virus is 315 feet or 96 meters
tall
7. cilla seen in godzilla king of the
monsters silla is a giant armored
cephalopod kaiju that awoke from
hibernation when monster zero sounded
its alpha call she has a head with ten
tendrils and tentacles orange eyes and
walks around with six bony and spiky
legs cilla's biology greatly resembles
that of a squid allowing her to survive
both on land and in water she is 341
feet or 104 meters tall
number six kraken
next we have the first kraken on this
list
it's from the clash of the titans the
remake from 2010. this behemoth of a
monster is a civil board of tremendous
size over 400 feet tall or more than 122
meters in height his tentacles are large
enough to be able to pull entire ships
under the water and destroy cities with
relative ease he was summoned by the
gods in the ancient past to help them
defeat the titans and in the movie
it was summoned again to destroy a city
but was killed by the glare of medusa's
head
number five the mind flayer also known
as the shadow monster this is the main
antagonist of the second and third
seasons of stranger things the mind flay
is a tentacle entity that resides in the
parallel dimension known as the upside
down it is a massively powerful being of
unknown origin being 50 stories tall or
more than 500 feet that's more than 150
meters in height
number four there's a teleport from an
old film called it came from beneath the
sea this is a huge six-armed jet
propulse malus capable of achieving
great speed on the open oceans its
natural habitat is the philippine sea
but it was driven away by nuclear bomb
testings which also resulted in its body
becoming dangerously radioactive it is
around 500 to 600 feet or 150 to 180
meters long
number three the kraken yet another
kraken on this list is the one from the
pirates of the caribbean
even though they stated the creature as
being more than 1400 feet long its true
size as seen in the movies is way lesser
than that
but then this ship killing titan of a
monster is still on the number third
spot on this list with our estimates
putting it around 500 to 600 feet in
length it is many tentacle and is a true
octopus monster
number two the singing kraken the last
kraken on this list is one that sings
and appears on the animated movie huddle
transylvania part
blair blair the kraken is a massive
bluish purple sea creature with a huge
mouth with long sharp teeth he has two
big black eyes and his numerous
tentacles are shown to be even larger
than the legacy hotel it is stated to be
more than 1800 feet or 550 meters tall
and number one the summa verminoth
another star wars monster the summer
vermont is a massive space-born species
that lived in the academy's maelstrom
around the planet castle at 7 432 meters
or more than 24 000 feet long it is the
largest on this list it has multiple
eyes and numerous large tentacles a sumo
vominar's tentacles were armed with a
suckers and electrified stingers but
even though deadly this monster was
killed in a black hole
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam
you